understanding of the situation what is
now being done
in taking this decision to make
seafarers redundant piano have also
today informed us they will be
suspending services for approximately a
week to 10 days while they locate new
crew
the affected routes are
dover to calais
land can ryan
dublin to liverpool
and hull to motto rotterdam
i know members right across the house mr
deputy speaker will share my concern
over the loss of these routes
i should stress that pianos say they are
only temporary and that alternative
provision will be provided by other
operators to whom i am extremely
grateful
passengers will still be able to travel
to and from the uk including across the
channel
with freight coming in and out of the
country
i understand that dfds is stepping in to
provide alternative services for
passengers with valid tickets and i
would like to thank dfds for their swift
action
however
i must warn travellers that they should
expect some disruption over the coming
days
i've asked my officials to liaise with
the kent resilience forum and cabinet
office to closely manage traffic in kent
over the coming days while piano work to
restore services
today the dover tap has been activated
those members will know this is not all
that uncommon there is some queuing on
jubilee way although the port of dover
expect this to reduce over the afternoon
i've also asked officials to remain in
close contact with other resilience
forums around the country as well as the
devolved administrations in managing
this issue
madam deputies mr deputy speaker we have
of course long planned contingencies for
situations
for disruption particularly around the
channel and i do not expect the supply
of critical goods and services to be
impacted as a result of this decision by
pno
although cues on the way to dover are
more likely uh to
occur at times
modeling suggests we have sufficient
capacity to handle the temporary loss of
these piano ferries
let me now turn to the issue of the
seafarers mr deputy speaker
these are hard-working dedicated staff
who have given years in service to
pno the way they have been treated today
is wholly unacceptable
and my thoughts are first and foremost
with them
reports of workers being given zero
notice
and escorted off their ships with
immediate effect
while being told cheaper alternatives
would take up their roles
shows the insensitive way in which p
have approached this issue
a point i have made crystal clear to
piano's management when i spoke to them
earlier this afternoon
as i told peter hebelthwaite
i am extremely concerned and frankly
angry
at the way
workers have been treated today by piano
as a matter of urgency i've asked my
department to liaise closely with
counterparts in the department for work
and pensions to ensure that workers are
being signposted to the most relevant
support
and i'm intending to call the trade
unions immediately after this statement
to discuss the situation with them
mr deputy speaker
there can be no doubt that the pandemic
has had a devastating impact on the
finances of many travel companies
including piano
but while their finances are matters for
them and them alone to take i would have
expected far better for the workers
involved
we will of course continue to engage
closely over the coming days
i commend this statement to the house
louise
thank you very much uh mr deputy speaker
the action taken by piano ferries today
is a national scandal it is a betrayal
of the workers that have kept this
country stocked throughout the pandemic
i've heard directly from the crew
throughout the day their lives are
pended the jobs they depended on
scrapped
workers are now left wondering how on
earth they will put food on their
family's table
and the management did not even have the
decency to tell them face to face they
were told this life-changing news on a
pre-recorded video
there are images circulating of what we
are told are handcuffed trained security
some wearing balaclavas marching british
crew off their ships
this is not a corporate restructure it's
not the way we go about business in this
country it is beneath contempt the
action of thugs it is quite simply a
scandal that this dubai owned company
which received millions of pounds of
taxpayers money in the pandemic without
consultation and without notice have
appended the lives of 800 british
workers
all while the profits of their owners dp
world soared by 52 percent in the first
half of 2021. we need a clear
unequivocal statement from the
government no ifs no buts an overseas
conglomerate cannot be given free reign
to sac workers in secure jobs here in
britain at the click of a button and
replace them with agency staff the
government must not give the green light
to this appalling practice and must act
now to secure the livelihoods of these
workers not signpost them to the
department of work and pensions mr
deputy speaker this cannot stand so will
the minister review any and every
contract and license the government has
with p o or dpw to maximize leverage and
force them to do the right thing dpw run
two of the government's free port
schemes will he look at terminating
those contracts will he convene urgent
talks with p o and the unions to look
immediately at what steps can be taken
to safeguard these jobs and can he
confirm if the secretary of state
received notification as required under
the 1992 trade union act
given neither the workers nor their
unions receive notification this action
is clearly illegal so will he act
immediately and ensure all those party
to the decision are appropriately
proceeded against
will he join me in condemning clyde
marine and interserve in the role they
have apparently played in today's events
and investigate any action that we can
taken against them and will he outline
the full extent to which other operators
will be able to cover this unacceptable
disruption it is impossible to conceive
that we have sufficient capacity to
cover a loss of 10 days finally will he
look at clawing back every single penny
of taxpayers money given to pno over the
course of the pandemic
but mr deputy speaker this must be set
within a context for far too long this
government has sat on their hands and
chosen to side with bad bosses by
failing to take action to outlaw fire
and rehire this is the cruel consequence
of a decade of attacks on workers rights
no more excuses it's time for ministers
to keep the promises they have made
deliver for workers rights and outlaw
fire and rehire without delay
and finally mr deputy speaker
we are an island nature
nation
british seafaring has been and is the
envy of the world
we are rightly proud of the british
sailors ratings and officers who make
our fleet and whose name is known across
the globe this is a straightforward
assault on british seafaring it cannot
be allowed to stand the government must
stand up speak out and take action for
these proud workers to protect their
livelihoods
minister
thank you mr deputy speaker and i thank
uh your honourable member for her
comments
she's quite right
lives up ended
jobs scrapped my sympathy my thoughts
are holy with those people have this
terrible news this morning she's
absolutely right i've seen the video
that she refers to
i agree
uh this is devastating news and to have
that played to you on a television
screen rather than being told
face-to-face is not what we expect the
way
loyal hard-working
workers
should be treated
likewise crews being marched off she
mentions
i've heard the same reports i expect
people to be treated with dignity and
respect at all times throughout their
employment
the there are of course employment laws
that apply
difficult for me at the moment to
comment in any detail as to where that
might be i would urge anyone affected to
consider legal advice and that's clearly
something they should do and difficult
for me to comment on that particularly
this is a fast-moving
situation
asks me uh to uh review contracts uh
that may exist i have asked my officials
to do that i can't give her any details
at the moment i apologize but i will be
able to provide information to the house
in due course if required um
conversations around freeport's course
would have to take place across
government
conversation with treasury and uh and
the department for communities uh in
particular she asked me to convene
urgent talks with the unions i will
speak to unions this afternoon uh in
fact maybe that's an initial
conversation there'll be others but i
need no persuading that will happen
uh uh she's mentioned the illegality
again i ought not to go into this but
clearly there are a number of concerns
the government has and i would urge
those to take the advice that they will
need she's asked me to give
details of the operations this is of
course fast moving situation whilst i am
assured that there is not likely to be
an operations impact i will be
monitoring that closely i can give her
some more detail uh when i have it and
of course if there is any steps to be
taken i would consider uh what those uh
were
she's asked she's made contact about
context
i of course
reject any suggestion that we've signed
with bad bosses i've been absolutely
clear
this today and on other occasions about
how i expect people to be treated with
respect
at all times
and i've been absolutely clear about
that today that is not the way people
have been treated
no one should be treated in the way that
they were today
and in terms of seafarers we will
continue to do everything we can to
support british seafarers and i hope to
be able to speak class in more detail
about that in due course
chair of the transport select committee
humerum
mr deputy speaker i thank you for
granting this statement and i thank the
minister for delivering it so robustly
piano this once great flag carry of the
seas have made an appalling error if
they do not reverse immediately and
reinstate the employees and follow
proper process it's hard to see away
back from them commercially the parent
dp world needs to understand that the
british public will not do business with
companies who treat their employees with
such contempt
can i ask that the government does
everything within its power and
influence including tabling emergency
legislation if needed to ensure that
this appalling employment transaction
cannot be completed
uh thank you mr speaker i thank my
honourable friend for his comments uh
this is a fast moving situation and we
are also reviewing uh the situation as
it as it develops and as it exists uh i
will certainly be reviewing uh the uh
what arrangements exist as we go forward
i can certainly commit to working with
all government departments to consider
what relationships we have with piano
i will review those
and i will also look to see whether
there is anything i can do in the
particular circumstances we are dealing
with here although of course
commercial matters for a company are
primarily a matter for them within the
constrains of employment law which of
course in this country is high and there
are standards that we expect to be
respected and upheld emily newlands
thank you mr deputy speaker can i thank
the minister for advancing your
statement and can i also agree with
every word that the shadow secretary and
the chair of the select committee um has
just said i said ella today that the
actions of pino were deeply concerning
but as more information has emails it's
become clear those actions are shameful
and sensitive and actually inhumane
the government's response to the the
fire rehab scandal where it was lip
service one word saying family how is
shameful but stubbornly refusing to back
those words up with any legislative
action uh mr deputies because that an
action has consequences
what pino have done today in sacking 800
workers over zoom without any notice or
consultation and dragging them from the
place of work using using handcuff
trained private security personnel as
well beyond even fire and rehire
of course
our primary concern must be for the
traumatized p o staff and their families
now jobless having gone to work like any
other day so will the minister support
those staff that remain aboard aboard
penal vessels and colin pino to end
their attempts to forcibly remove staff
of course the villain in all of this is
p o and the parent company dp world a
company owned by anti-trade union
oligarchs in dubai who have a shockingly
bad track record in employment relations
and pino's plans to have entirely new
crews operated vessels with zero or
little acclimatization period it does
manage to not agree that pino's
aim to resume shipping with ustaff
almost immediately is reckless and
unsafe and finally mr deputy speaker
the prime minister was visiting the
united arab emirates yesterday was there
a discussion between the prime minister
and the dubai government the owners of
dp world on pino
and lastly i mean at this time mr deputy
speaker
the minister said this is a commercial
decision for them and them alone to take
i would have expected far better for the
workers involved i agree mr deputy
speaker but i would also expect far far
better protection for our workers from
the government of the day so can the
minister confirm if there's anything
anything at all the government can do to
intervene to help these workers and if
not does that not highlight yet again
just how broken uk employment law is
so i i entirely hear um the uh
anger and anguish that's been expressed
by all gentlemen and i i know he speaks
on behalf of
probably constituents um certainly
people that he represents and i hear
that
i would encourage all employees in any
event to speak to their hard-working
loyal
long-serving employees i would certainly
engage that they urge them to engage
with the unions who i would have hoped
would have been spoken to in advance in
any event in any such incidents that
will cause distress to workers
and certainly one such as this i would
urge them to do that
safety matters uh these it
is still an evolving situation and
clearly there are safety regulations
have to be applied and complied with in
any case no matter who's crewing a
vessel and i would expect that to be the
case clearly there will be no shortcuts
as far as safety is concerned
and we will continue to look
across government and to speak
to colleagues and uphold
the rights that are clear in law
to protect
workers
[Applause]
natalie elfic
thank you mr deputy speaker my right
honourable friend will he agree with me
that the way in which piano ferries and
dp world have acted is shabby
disgraceful and utterly unacceptable
they have mistreated
600
loyal workers in dover
and in addition to this they have
brought traffic disruption and put at
risk the economy and the trade routes
through it
will he meet with me to discuss what
more can be done to hold them to account
to hold dp world and piano ferries to
account for their disgraceful behaviour
i thank our honourable friend for that
and for speaking out so powerfully and
forcefully on behalf of her constituents
who will be anguished
hurt and distraught at the news that
they have been given today she speaks
for them and i thank her for doing so i
will of course meet with her i'll meet
with any honourable right honourable
member from anywhere across the house to
discuss any concerns that they or their
constituents might have she asks me do i
agree
with that the way that piano have
behaved is unacceptable yes mr deputy
speaker it's unacceptable yeah
rosie duffield thank you mr deputy
speaker does the minister acknowledge
that my constituency of canterbury in
east kent as a whole will be
particularly affected by today's
shocking news what urgent support will
the government give to all those
affected locally including the hundreds
of piano workers treated disgracefully
disgracefully as we've just heard now
facing no pay packet at all in the face
of the soaring cost of living they don't
want a work coach they just want their
jobs back
not to mention the beleaguered residents
of east kent who yet again will have to
bear the brunt of serious disruption in
our daily lives and i'm glad to hear the
minister will meet with mps across east
kent that really needs to be urgently
done thank you
thank you and again i thank the
honourable member for the question that
she's put on first again speaking out
and making her constituents
understandable anguish so clear in this
place it's entirely heard by me
and i share it she speaks with anger
i've expressed that anger in person to
piano today because of the effect this
will be having on people living in her
constituency and elsewhere at the news
that they have had particularly at this
time which in any event is a time that
is causing uh you know much uncertainty
for many people i'd be delighted to meet
with her uh and any others who would uh
who would like to meet with me to
discuss what we may be able uh to do
i referred earlier in my statement to
some signposting within dwp that is some
support that is available if there are
other things that will be helpful i'm
very happy to hear from her uh and she
lastly referred to disruption i i there
may be some disruption the
the only
happy side of things is that we are able
to we have uh some good well-rehearsed
procedures in place to deal with that
disruption i totally accept that they
will cause her
inconvenience to her constituents but i
hope that the well-practiced routines we
have in place will keep that to a
minimum
so john hayes
mr speaker as shipping minister i
oversaw the maritime growth study
to build on success in the sector the
heart of which was the skills to build
an even stronger merchant navy
this capricious
careless callus decision piano flies in
the face of all of that
so will my honourable friend work my old
friends in the ira time section of the
rmt
and others to recover any monies granted
to piano uh during the pandemic to
ensure they reverse this decision
and don't let anyone tell me this is the
free market the free market puts little
girls in
factories and boils down mines and both
at risk on the high seas we thought
those dark days are gone piano are
either too dim to see that or too
dastardly to know it
my right honourable friend's absolutely
right about the skills that have been
demonstrated by extraordinary british
seafarers over the course of many years
this is something that is key to the
government's
vision of what it wants to achieve it's
something that's particularly important
to me
personally and we remain committed to
doing what we can to support seafarers
and all the strategies that the
honourable of the house have heard me
talk about before through maritime 2015
and onwards remain the case that focus
on maritime skills remains the case the
government is still determined to do all
it can to grow british seafarers and to
make this and to continue this to be a
maritime nation as it's always been that
horrible friend my original friend can
be assured remains undimmed uh he also
reports who speaks quite rightly about
employment rights they are extensive in
this country they're there for a good
reason
they continue government supports them
johnson thank you mr deputy speaker as
the mp for liverpool riverside i'm
disgusted by the actions of pino today
liverpool's one of the routes are going
to be affected by this action and it's
another example of fire and rehire by a
despicable employer but while this
government has stood by and ignored it
actions speak louder than words minister
so let's take some decisive action
against piano thank you
[Applause]
again i understand still remembers anger
on her constituents entirely i know they
will be affected i'm i'm acutely aware
of that this is we don't know all the
circumstances yet i ought to just
caution her as to whether this is a fire
in high risk situation or some other
situation what i absolutely am clear
about in any event yep my own remember
says you know i'm happy to repeat it for
they have fired 800 stuff she's right
and i've been absolutely clear about my
view of the way in which this has been
done i'm merely making a point about
the contractual arrangements that exist
we need to understand that i will
continue to work with her and others to
see what we can do to help
goodson thank you
thank my honourable friend for coming to
the house source with me today we are
all shocked outraged and appalled at the
treatment of p staff today and i welcome
the minister's condemnation of these
dreadful employment practices
will he continue to update the house on
this unfolding situation
yeah
yes i'm acutely conscious mr deputy
speaker that i have there are some
details i haven't been able to give
today because the situation is evolving
and there are some things yet that we
don't know and i don't know as and when
i do know of course i will give the
information that is required be that
verbally and or in some other way
then diana johnson thank you mr deputy
speaker and i want to speak on behalf of
my honourable friends for hull east and
hull western hessel and the people of
hull who stand tonight
united in our utter disgust at what has
happened to the seafarers that we're
discussing that have been sacked by p o
and it's simply a lie that p must sack
800 british workers to survive p o last
year paid out 270 million to
shareholders as well as taking furlong
money from taxpayers and the government
has to be really clear here about who
they back
and they cannot just say this is a
commercial decision this is a choice
between predatory employers sucking
workers on zoom in their leveling down
race to the bottom or our loyal
hard-working uk workers fighting for
their jobs so will the minister
tell the house that he will
instruct
dubai based dp world
to stand down the replacement crews
to send the security muscle home
and to reinstate those who've been
sacked immediately
i thank god blade for speaking on behalf
of hull and her right honourable friends
to make their voices heard today i am
absolutely clear and her question of
itself shows the importance of the
maritime sector the entirety of our
united kingdom because from every corner
of our united kingdom today there are
honourable right honourable members
expressing their anguish on behalf of
their constituents and their own
feelings of course as well and she's
quite right
of course that um the furlough money
would have been available to pno so the
government has supported this company as
it supported the whole of the economy
during the pandemic
she says
are we on the side of leveling down race
to the bottom no we're not i've been
absolutely clear today there are rights
we expect them to be maintained and
supported and she says are we on the
side of those hard-working workers yes
we absolutely are yeah you know
thank you mr t my background is maritime
minister robert court's there speaking
to the house of commons after piano
ferries uh made 800 staff redundant with
immediate effect and also carry
cancelled all of their ferry user as
well so mr courts there saying no one
should be treated this way saying the
government is fully behind
the workers he did say uh procedures are
in place uh to help those affected uh
the passengers affected with other
companies uh stepping in
well in a moment we'll be speaking to
skies either bennett who's in dover for
us but first let's go to our political
correspondent joe pike and joe
mr courts saying that he shared the
anger of mps it expressed that anger to
piano today
is there much that ministers can
actually do
we didn't really detail a huge amount of
support the government could give did he
rob a courts the maritime minister he
said they could sign post people to help
from the department of work and pensions
but also perhaps significantly he said
that he had instructed his civil
servants officials to review
any contracts the government does have
with piano and piano of course is a
company that deals with passengers as
well as freight but it's hard to i think
if that company had really predicted
such
a united and angry response from the
house of commons that they had expected
to be so roundly condemned by
parliamentarians not for what they have
done but from for how they have done it
clearly they are in a difficult
situation arguing they need to be more
competitive and efficient they have this
100 million pound black hole cumulative
over the last three years they've lost
about 250 million pounds the pandemic
has clearly not helped perhaps the
northern ireland protocol has added
some impediments too but quite how this
has happened uh pretty brutally people
being told without any consultation that
it is over and you are out uh clearly
has gone down very very badly not just
with the uk government but also the
scottish government too nicolas sturgeon
scotland's first minister presumably
very worried about employees on the
route between ken ryan of course in the
south
west of scotland what was stran ra close
by that route from ken ryan to land she
has spoken
to the ceo of pno and she's tweeted this
about her conversation i have just
spoken directly to the ceo of piano and
made clear my utter disgust at this
appalling treatment of its workers i
made clear that scottish government
stands with these workers and will do
everything possible to ensure fair
treatment for them but as you point out
sophie
how powerless are the government is
there much they can do we heard from one
conservative select committee uh chair
hugh merriman uh who said that
effectively pno should reverse um their
decision uh it was appalling error and
it's hard to see a way back for the
company unless they reverse that
decision is that likely i'm unsure we
haven't heard much from the company
since their original statement but
certainly i think with that that
widespread combination uh condemnation
sorry from all sides of the house this
seems at this stage a pr disaster for
the ferry company
uh it does doesn't it joe uh thank you
very much for uh that
let's go now to either bennett shall we
uh who's in dover
uh for us and either what is the
situation where you are
so i'm stood outside the uh cruise
terminal actually um of the port of
dover because behind these gates
is are the three p ferries that have
been moored up here stationary since
this morning when the company suspended
all sailings um we understand that there
are actually still some pno staff who
have been made redundant still on board
the rmt union we know have has been
advising its members uh not to leave the
ships in in protest at this um uh mass
redundancies these mass layoffs but in
this case uh we understand that actually
uh the staff is not a case of them uh
refusing to leave it's actually they're
just waiting to be able to leave
gathering all their stuff and then being
let out uh gradually and we know that
because i've spoken to two piano staff
who have just walked out these gates and
they didn't want to speak on camera
because of non-disclosure agreements
they've signed in their contracts that
might prevent them getting any
redundancy payouts
but they did tell me that they've been
working for the company in one case six
years another case 25 years
and they found out they lost their jobs
this morning at around 11 o'clock via
zoom in a a meeting that lasted or
announcement that lasted around three
minutes all very abrupt they had no
prior warning and they've basically been
left uh high and dry and as i said um
some of their colleagues are still on
board waiting to be
let off now unions are of course furious
about this calling it a betrayal of
british workers nothing short of
scandalous because these um the 800 who
have been laid off which are right from
the top captains all the way down to say
check-in staff cleaners
loaders
engine room engineers as well they're
going to be replaced by foreign agency
workers and a few minibuses have
gradually been going in here
to go and
board the ferries and i spoke to a few
of them they've flown in from latvia
romania and georgia
and they all said they flew in this
morning having signed temporary
contracts last night so it's all been
very hastily
arranged
and a huge impact obviously for those
who have been laid off but also impacts
the passengers too
the company is warning of significant
disruption ahead with all sailing
suspended for the next few days um today
though
what we've seen at the the port of dover
where the ferries leave in that
direction there hasn't actually been
much much disruption at all that we've
seen because um or whilst there has been
a line of lorries that's actually quite
normal for this time of day this time of
uh the week according to the officials
here
anyone who does have a ticket for a
piano crossing they're actually being
redirect and rebooked on other carriers
and that operation seems to have worked
quite smoothly but as i say the company
piano is warning of significant
disruption ahead for any passengers
booked and of course significant
disruption for the lives of
all those 800 staff who have been laid
off thank you
well good evening from la viv in western
ukraine it is day 22 of russia's
invasion a campaign which according to
western intelligence has stalled on
virtually all fronts but still the
ukrainian people paid the price for
russia's aggression in mariupol a rescue
effort is underway after the bombing of
a theatre where more than one thousand
people were thought to be taking shelter
that prom